هكذا بدا المشهد قبل وقوع هجوم حركه
الشباب الصومالي على مجمع ويست جيت
التجاري في كينيا وفجاه تتغير الصوره
فيبدا الرجال والنساء والاطفال بالركض
للنجاه بحياتهم ويبدو هذا الرجل ممددا على
الارض قبل ان يطلق عليه احد المسلحين
النار
ويصيبه بعدها يحاول ان يستجمع قواه ليزحف
خارجا لكن ما يلبث وياتي مسلح اخر ليقتله
بلا
رحمه وهنا رصدت الكاميرات الامنيه اثنين
من المهاجمين وهم يشقون طريقهم الى موقف
للسيارات من ثم يقومون بفتح النار وفي
الوقت الذي وقع فيه الهجوم داخل المجمع
التجاري يلاحظ الكثير من الناس اليائسين
وهم يحاولون الهرب للنجاه بحياتهم بينما
تنهمر الطلقات الناريه من كل الاتجاهات
ولم يشفع لهذا الرجل موته فيطلق عليه مسلح
رصاصه اخرى وفي قسم المواد الغذائيه تظهر
امراه وطفليها في حين تضع احدهما في عربه
للتسوق بعد ان
اصيب وهنا تظهر فتاه مراهقه وهي ترفع
يديها والدماء تغطي
ملابسها السلطات الكينيه قالت انها راقبت
عن كثب الكاميرات الامنيه خلال لحظات وقوع
الهجوم حيث كان يظهر الخاطفون وهم يتحدثون
عبر الهاتف الامر الذي جعل الشرطه تعتقد
انهم كانوا يتلقون تعليماتهم من خارج
المجمع التجاري وهنا يظهر مسلح اخر وهو
يتفقد كاميرات
المراقبه اما هنا فيتنا هؤلاء المسلحون
على الصلاه بعد ساعات على بدء الهجوم وفي
ردهه المطاعم داخل المجمع التجاري يظهر
مسلح يبدو انه غربي الملامح ورجل امن
يرتدي زي الشرطه الكينيه اثناء محاولتهم
حمايه الموظفين ومرتادي المطاعم
المذعورين